[Music]
[Applause]
why would i betray we all have our
secrets we just didn't get to yours yet
this is the 25th Bond film
this is your fifth Bond film and this is
your final time portraying the character
of James Bond
what is something unique and important
that you want it to bring to the role
this time around that maybe we haven't
seen from the character in the previous
films god god that's um I mean you know
there's a with there's a throw line to
the movies there's a first being a very
strong through line whether by whether
it's been deliberate or just by the fact
that it just seemed to be the right
thing to do when we went the movies this
is this a lot there were lots of there
were a lot of what I felt like sort of
unsaid things at the end of Spectre that
we put into the beginning of this film
and then the movie sort of blows up from
there and it's about so many other
things that I kind of dumb into you must
have mentioned I want to give anything
away which includes all of these people
and all of the normal people been and
and Naomi and uh thank you Ray what if
Ray for is it fine and it's it's a kind
of for me having all of these characters
and all of these sort of storylines and
all of these things sort of mashing up
together it's about the relationships
and about family that's what the movies
and it's about love dare I say may I
speak to the relationships the last time
we saw Madeleine and James they were
riding off into the sunset where do we
pick up elbow into the sunset that's a
good there's a mission I don't think the
Sun was shining it was London where
where do we pick up this time around and
and where is she and and how does the
character evolve in this film what can
you say so it's right after right after
Spectre I mean when we when was he
James Bond and Madeline they are in love
at the beginning everything is perfect
almost perfect until until it's just a
mess yeah there are more complicated
Space Station crashes into the North
Atlantic
it's just like I don't know mercury is
another great spoilers
Carrie this is your your skeletons your
biggest fault today what was something
personal that you wanted to bring to
this franchise now 25 films in what was
something you were looking to bring to
it that's hard to say because I think it
was a definitely collective approach
right to crafting the story but I think
the emotionality was something that I
was interested in and wanted to explore
wouldn't want to get deeper into the
psychology of bond after the tragedy of
his Malaysian ship with Vesper Lynd
and Casino Royale and now with the the
new relationship metal and Swan what
would all that baggage bringing all that
baggage into this new relationship mean
was it cool to be in Jamaica the the
home of Ian Fleming was that did that
mean a lot when you were there and did
you sort of take take a moment to sort
of look back and say this is cool
literally cool it was hot as hell but
was it did it feel meaningful to sort of
be there telling this story where he
lived we got to stay at Goldeneye which
is pretty wonderful experience because
it's it's a very nice place to stay it
felt right no it felt like
you mean we're making a bomb movie so it
has to feel like a Bond movie and that
felt like a Bond movie definitely felt
going up the spiritual home and there
was a certain it's some of something you
can't really intellectualize until
you're sitting there at the desk where
Fleming wrote looking at the sea and
thinking about how all his experiences
in the war plus obvious Majan Asian
brought about this character James Bond
that's become so iconic Geoffrey Felix
is always pulling the guy back in he's
he's hanging he's chill he's enjoying
life not in service but he comes to pull
him back in what can you say about why
he needs James Bond in you know
Godfather that was Al Pacino's line you
know the you know slightly lighter pulls
me back in they changed it on the day
but but yeah in this instance he he does
draw draw him back into the game and I
think in I think it has to do I think it
speaks to a Daniel was talking about in
terms and also carry in terms of the
intimacy of the film the kind of
emotionality it's really you know in the
midst of everything that happens in
these films it's really about these
relationships and it's about this kind
of Brotherhood that they belong to and
the sense of you know kinship that they
that they have between between them that
draws them in you know the curves beyond
who they work for
yeah and who they're loyal to in their
professional lives it's about a
relationship that's built on complete
trust and yeah Andrew younge
questionable trust who you want who you
want with you in the foxhole yeah you
know there are many people that he does
trust no Phoenix is definitely let's
come over leshawna leshawna Internet has
been ablaze speculating on who you play
in this film would you know that she is
a double O agent how would you say hard
double O agent maybe is
different from James Bond that
completely drew people to their job
completely different mindsets he has a
more classic way and more and more of an
how do you say he just tells his own
thing I think you have your own free way
of doing things and I have my Fiverr
book kind of teacher's pet way of
getting the job done I think they both
just want to be the best of what they do
then you know I think there's a certain
amount of cynicism in bond at this point
that clashes with your your yeah your
kind of hunger - yeah and that's
interesting they're really interesting
kind of clash yeah I mean it's a clash
there's a clash at the beginning for
sure when you see them working together
it actually makes for quite a beautiful
partnership actually and I think they
get the job done in a and efficient way
yeah they get the job done but they have
to go through this gentleman sitting
between your Robbie's how do you know
that talk about your character and sort
of helping factors into the film and and
did you sort of look at other Bond
villains from from history for any kind
of inspiration a clip you know Carrie
and I spent quite a long time working on
it beforehand Jemaine oh it was like
almost a year ago we started talking
about this character before I even had a
chance to read the script
long before coming up with ideas and you
know every chance I got carrying her I
would you know just seep as much
information as possible as he was
you know putting the story together and
with the writers of course there's a
quality about Safin is a certain
philosophy on on how he can make the
world a better place and they can
benefit everyone including James Bond
himself and you know someone would call
him malicious or ruthless but I don't
think he sees it his actions that way at
all quite the opposite and if anything
his ruthlessness is a byproduct of a
ruthlessness that he might have had in
his own life at some point you know as
we begin to wrap up 25 films and I've
said that before what are you thinking
of is it about this character this
franchise that it has been able to
endure for 25 years and still entertain
audiences over and over again and they
still want more as as everyone here has
now been our veterans of James Bond
franchise what do you think it is about
the character I think it's I mean we've
said before but it's there are so many
moving parts to this film that so you
know stories escape in the press that
are mostly untrue and the sort of the
the excitement it seems to generate when
it's announced that there's going to be
another movie and that momentum just get
sort of snowballs as we get closer and
closer to to the release and the movies
have sustained a quality there that you
know they've always been fun they've
always been something to for everybody
to sort of get involved with and often a
family event which is great to take you
know to take the whole family to and
their proper event cinema I mean there's
nothing quite like them I think one of
the things you have to look to is the
stewardship of the the character there's
been a character that's been well taken
care of by Barbara probably Michael
Wilson you know and without you know
we're none of us are here without that
but the way that this this thing has
been
managed overtime I mean it really is
it's unique in that regard I mean it's
really a singular it's not it's not to
be taken for granted that it would
necessarily just go on simply because
these are dynamic stories and dynamic
characters but they have to be realized
and you know they've done that you know
over time so like greeting reasons I
think it actually vacations beautiful
people shows right it's not just the
character situations but he is a
compelling character and he has changed
over time the bond of dr. know and bond
of no time to die aren't necessarily the
same bonds they share a lot of qualities
but there's been a progression there and
he's a hero he's here the feels of the
real world somehow feels just plausible
enough and times like now and then
seems like throughout the last 60 years
it seems that we've always needed heroes
straddles two worlds doesn't it because
it's very kind of a Bond movie you do
very up-to-date they usually got
something that sort of reflects what's
going on in the world but they have one
foot firmly placed in the past so
there's so there's something unique
about them in that sense but and there's
all this history like he says 25 films
and that that informs the movie you
watch fraud too you know and I think we
all like our heroes a little bit flawed
I think that makes them just a little
bit more relatable I mean there's a lot
of things we all know we can't do we
can't be James Bond but I think you know
there's there's the humanity that I
think we all access at some point in
some way and you know he's an
international man of mystery right buddy
and every country has a relationship to
this man yeah everyone across the globe
can identify who James Bond is and wants
to go to these movies and there's just
something to be said about that it
it's a it's a phenomenon but it's it's
it makes sense because of what Ian
Fleming initially did and like you said
Geoffrey the stewardship and and the
collaboration that I think has existed
over the years and in this film as well
mmm great talented people coming
together and telling this guy's story
you know I've actually got gotten into
as a result of having been in this film
and played you know played lighter just
talking about the impact I've actually
gotten into some really hyper secretive
confidential spaces in the United States
government I'm not gonna say what cuz
you're serious oh you're lighter oh I
thought you were actually gonna give us
something about keeping secrets yeah
alright hug that though the film comes
out this April thank you so much and I
wish you all best of luck oh thank you
thank you very much
you